Hey time for the retrospective and look
I got my [ __ ] together in time to do a
review of Friday the 13th on actual
friend 30 yeah I keep saying that I was
gonna do that actually Friday 13th part
1 & 2 yeah we're gonna do the first two
because really I don't think it's a
terribly controversial opinion to say
that those are kind of the best ones
yeah I think there really wasn't that
good I thought it was good I saw it
again recently and I was like man I like
that movie
they're all fun but it's like you know
and I feel like The Kills got more
creative as it went on but as a from a
quality standpoint of being like a
quality slasher movie I think the first
yeah the best and really I the second
one the second one I think is the best
one and I don't really think that we're
the only like horror fans that say that
yeah most people like the second one the
best they're both good but the second
one's a lot more professional yeah I
definitely think so so basically it's so
funny to think about how just some
[ __ ] little thing that you know some
movie makers wanted to make like to
essentially Sean Cunningham who directed
and produced the first one he was like
he saw Halloween in 1978 and he was like
that's a cool movie that's making a lot
of money let's rip it off yeah he said
let's rip that [ __ ] off yeah now I he
said that he did say it but like the
writer Victor Miller so that's exactly
what he said he's like that's an exact
quote we're just gonna rip off Halloween
smart idea it was because you know
Halloween only costs what like three or
four hundred thousand dollars and made
like a lot of problems of dollars and
you know it in much of the same way
Friday the 13th kind of spawned a
massive franchise which is hilarious
considering how I mean the first movie
was just there was hardly anything to it
it cost them only a little over half a
million dollars to make and it ended up
making in 1980 dollars like 60 million
bucks which is something like a hundred
and twenty million like today's money
there was some trickery going on in this
movie when you think about though
trickery there's no real proof that the
first one took place on Friday the 13th
and I don't think the second one took
place on party
yeah maybe the first one kind of took
place on Friday 13th they didn't say
well um Betsy Palmer who played mrs.
Voorhees she does say that today is his
birthday and that was Friday the 13th I
guess and nothing's coming on the second
one and in the second one when they're
sitting around the campfire like talking
about it they say every Friday the 13th
blah-de-blah
or something like that so they do make
reference and a reference to it but they
never really prove that that's when it's
happening
it's just leave it kind of vague yeah
it's just a title well because it's a
good title yeah and then another thing
is is that the second movie was just to
be taking place at the same location but
in another camp they go to walk to the
old camp where the weird part one
walking like that and there they never
got there you know they did because it
was like a chain and they've like
stepped over it and then the cops came
yes they never they never they never got
to the actually I never got to the
action ever they didn't shoot at the
same place and obviously I was going
yeah let's see if that [ __ ] looked
like still you know and they never got
to it again which that's kind of
cheating but okay well really because
you know you just had to do what you do
way to do the kind of the amazing thing
and it's funny because we have I think
we have all of the furniture teeth
movies or just the breath just first
three just the first three yeah so we
have those on blu-ray so we've watched
like all the UM extra [ __ ]
and Sean Cunningham it's funny because
you know he kind of distanced himself
not because he didn't like it but just
because he was like working on other
[ __ ] and it's just hilarious how this
little ripoff of Halloween that he made
for like $550,000 grew to become this
[ __ ] massive phrase what is it like
12 movies counting the ones across over
with Friday or whatever and you know
people still he's one of the most iconic
jason who's one of the most iconic
horror villains and it's just funny how
they just came up with this nothing idea
and spent no money on it they filmed it
in New Jersey it was actually shot at an
actual Boy Scout camp which apparently
is still open yeah it looked like [ __ ]
it looks like crap for some reason like
I thought that I remember reading that
yes it was a real camp but it was
abandoned
was gonna be a bit that I thought yeah
because it looks like it was a bunch of
log cabins and it looks pretty cruddy I
mean it looked cruddy back then I can't
imagine what it would look like now
those can't be the same well it might
have been like renovated maybe it's the
Boy Scout camp
they must have tore that down build some
new I hope they did because it looked
like it was getting ready to fall down
in the first in 1980 as I was watching
the first one again and I was just
remember as man I remember I didn't
remember that camp looking that crappy
which actually helps to make it scary
yeah it's a real location and it looks
looks crap like [ __ ] on toast
yeah and that really kind of helps amp
up the suspense and I saw old the
bathrooms look all [ __ ] up yeah it's
like every it looks like every available
surface is just crawling yeah bacteria
it's like it stinks in there
furnitures so yeah so this whole thing
and what you were saying about Friday
the 13th like reminded me the whole
thing when they were first working on
the script because I think that Sean
Cunningham pretty much sold the idea
before the script was even done he's
basically like well we're doing a
slasher movie kind of like Halloween but
set out in the woods like with scampers
and [ __ ] and so the original draft of
the script I think was called uh you
know camp blood or something about like
lost something at Camp blood or
murderers camp blood or something like
that so then he came up with the idea of
he's like oh let's call it Friday the
13th is like another holiday sort of
thing so they thought that that would be
kind of a cool idea and initially this
is interesting too and this is something
I didn't know this was similar to the
idea that John Carpenter had for
Halloween
initially when after Friday the 13th
came out and it was like a massive
success it was like lines are on the
[ __ ] block to see it and everything
when they were talking about maybe
having to do another one he wanted to do
an anthology series just like John
Carpenter wanted to do after Halloween
TIA where he's just like well I want to
make a movie that comes out every year
that's called Friday the 13th
blah-dee-blah
but it's not the same character it's not
the same theme it's always like you know
kind of variations on a theme but they
were all like gonna be Stan
movies but that's not how it worked out
obviously now most people will know and
I'll think this is like a [ __ ]
spoiler alert or anything like that but
the first Friday the 13th which came out
in 1980 Jason is not really in it except
as a kid and even then when they show
him at the end you could argue that that
was a dream sequence which I think it
kind of is which is how they kind of
back dated it like when they did the
book in sequel so yeah so Jason's mom
mrs. Voorhees Pamela Voorhees played by
veteran actress Betsy Palmer is the
killer yeah she didn't want to be in it
it's hilarious because yeah she had been
like in like really like [ __ ] kind of
upscale sort of movies and I guess she'd
been on TV and everything and she was
kind of older at this point not that old
but you know she was 15 she was like an
older actress and they sent her this
script for some reason she wasn't the
first choice I think there was like
another similar type of TV or stage
actors that they approached but who
turned it down and so they give her the
script and she basically said and she
has been quoted as saying that she
thought the script was quote unquote a
piece of [ __ ] yeah
but because they said they were gonna
pay her ten thousand dollars and she
happened to need a new car at the time
she was like sure why not yeah and but
she did seem to get into it later
because she was saying I you know they
she's been at like a lot of conventions
and [ __ ] like that nowadays but she said
that the method acting that she used
she's like once I decided that I was
gonna be at this [ __ ] slasher movie
she's like I wanted to get a bead on
like the character so she's like so they
told me about you know in wardrobe she
had this class ring that she wore which
you can kind of see and in the movie
even though most of the time when they
show the hands it's not her hands it's
like the stunt man or whatever but she
said so that put me back in the 1940s
when I was in height when I was really
in high school and so she came up with
this whole elaborate backstory of like
her having sex with her boyfriend back
at the 40s at high school and getting
pregnant with Jason and then like her
parents like disowned her and that Jason
was born
he was strange in her words fishy that
was she well that's a big told she said
what kind of movie is this really funny
because I I think a lot of times
especially with productions kind of as
legit as this some of the actors didn't
know like what type of movie they were
gonna be like the guy that's in it that
plays like the kind of jokey character
the one that's always like running
around with the [ __ ] headdress and
all that kind of crazy yeah he didn't
know that it was a slasher movie he
basically thought it was just like kind
of summer teen drama or something like
that
and then he's like so I'm because they
only gave me like a page of the script
like to read and then I get the part and
then he's like hey you need to come in
and like wear a bathing suit and he's
like what the [ __ ] it's all of a sudden
and then he reads the whole script that
he's like it's all bloody and everything
so a lot of people were confused about
what type of movie it was gonna be I do
that on purpose because they're
privately back out maybe they would
because you have to say I mean now you
know nowadays I feel like it's not um
the stigma that it once was like to be
in horror movies because I feel like yes
yeah like back then you cut it was like
I was almost like doing porn it's like
once you did that it was kind of like
you were ruined for everybody was gone
your career was over which is kind of
hilarious to think of I mean in the
first movie in case you guys didn't know
the one that came out in 1980 Kevin
Bacon was in that [ __ ] yeah it wasn't
his first movie I think he'd been in
like another kind of cheap-ass movie
before that but it didn't hurt his
career what's funny is that these
cheap-ass movies stood the test of time
they're all remembered there's a button
bunch of classics they're all forgotten
yeah I think like a lot of dramas and
stuff like that
came out in 1980 people don't talk about
them as passionately yeah and we've kind
of talked about that before and like I
was thinking about it when we were
watching a lot of the extras that are on
the Friday the 13th DVDs where they have
like all these interviews with all the
you know people that were in it like the
conventions and stuff and I feel like I
mean horror fans and sci-fi fans are
like the most loyal [ __ ] people and
it's like they if you were in a movie
like back in [ __ ] 1968 and it was just
like some little part in some like
really good horror movie people will
remember you
forever yeah the woman that played Jason
Voorhees their mom victimizer mom she
had no idea she just when it made all
that money she just couldn't believe it
yeah she couldn't believe it and then
she came back and did the sequel - and
yeah briefly but they wanted her to come
back was that a comport 5 or part 6
yeah I think they asked her to come back
or it might have been the Freddy vs.
Jason that they asked yeah back she said
that the the she cared about the
characters she said the the lines that
the character had she's it was just [ __ ]
she wouldn't do it yeah she thought the
script said if she were gonna come back
as no job she's gonna have to have a
real role and half you know I mean a
real part in the movie she's like yeah I
think that's kind of cool that she you
know probably did right by the fans and
that character by not you know selling
that character out because if you're
gonna use that character [ __ ] use it
she hasn't changed much she looked a lot
like she looked exactly like she did at
least pretty much I mean she's in her
80s yeah and she looked about the same I
mean that was yeah the convention that
they shop for the DVD I think it was
from 2008 yeah we so made her 70s and
this I don't know has she passed away at
this point I didn't know I didn't fix
that she had I would think she'd be in
the 70s and she was still in good shape
yes just talking about being in a mood
10 years but prior to that so she would
have still to look at the same yeah and
I think that might handed up being her
main source of income and later on in
life she was like enjoyed yeah doing it
doing this she does all the conventions
better yeah
same haircut adorable yeah it's adorable
yeah and it's it's just funny that like
I said back in the day when you know
when horror movies were kind of like
looked at askance particularly in the
late 70s and early 80's when you know
there was still kind of that grindhouse
aesthetic or you know that people had
that perception of horror movies like I
said it was almost kind of like porn
that's where you want it were for kids
though it wasn't respected yeah you know
it's like teenagers and [ __ ] like that
which was the audience that they were
trying to I first saw it you know that
they were trying to get you but it's
just funny like you said that those
movies have stood the test of time I
mean Friday the 13th for Christ's sake
which if you see it nowadays in light of
horror all the horror movies that have
come subsequently they're lightweight it
really doesn't seem
like anything and it really doesn't seem
like it would have been such a huge
cultural phenomenon and it's funny that
at the time I guess like you know in
1980 it was considered pretty gory or
pretty shocking like some stuff was cut
out of it I thought it was I mean I
first saw probably like on HBO and
Cinemax they would they would run part 1
and part 2 yeah on the same night so you
could watch them you know a double peach
they had that [ __ ] drunk and running all
the time specially during the summers
and I never saw him in the theater I saw
him on cable and they scared the [ __ ]
out of me I'd be up in Mississippi for
the summers in the in wooded areas you
know what I mean and just Jason was
outside every window after all you know
me and me and other guys my age you know
we [ __ ] would stay up late watch that
[ __ ] you know sneaking drinks and [ __ ]
you know we were probably you know 13 14
around that time and the main draw was
there they were cute girls in it yeah
and the [ __ ] was scary yeah and we
thought it was gory but I went back and
looked at it you know just the past
couple days we've been watching them
know there's not much in them
hardly anything Arlene in him it's
mostly just suggestion especially the
first one and it's interesting because
like I said that they that it got so
much flack for being gory and even like
a lot of the reviews if you read them
like from the time that came out at the
time and they're talking about how
violent and gory and stuff it is there's
really only two or three scenes like
murders and they look great because Tom
Savini did them this was one of his you
know first movies he done Dawn of the
Dead prior to this and that's why he got
called on to do this movie and he did
like the beheading still looks great you
know there's an axe in the face there's
um you know the the arrow that comes out
through Kevin Bacon's neck and stuff
looks good
but it's only a few frames it's only
yeah it's only a couple of frames so
it's just hilarious how cuz I had a
perception too that it was gory and it
had this reputation and then when you
see it now I'm like that's it it's like
I've seen [ __ ] kids movies you know
that's a little boy you'll see the ax
being swung and then in the next shot
the axe is already in to get out of her
face he says never you never actually
saw it go in but in those days when you
were that age with you know I mean the
expectations of time
your mind you saw that act yeah it
filled stuff in yeah because I feel like
the same thing happened with Texas
Chainsaw Massacre than a lot of people
because people had a perception because
of the title obviously because it's very
lurid title and because when you see it
it's just like this really upsetting
like gross like gritty experience but
when you see it again there's nothing
there's like hardly anything in it and
we were man we were kids we [ __ ] love
this [ __ ] it's just like the movies were
tailored to like the male gaze alright
bouncing boobies and man it was illegal
to wear a bra backpack news everybody
and it must have been cold as [ __ ] watch
me as I because the one girl like it
like especially in part to you that
frizzy hair girl yeah she doesn't ever
like show her boobs they're usually in
the first one I don't think they show
any boobs now that but you thought he
did it yeah I thought they did because
so they did a number on yeah it was all
suggestion and I couldn't want us when I
saw part two again when I saw the frizzy
hair girl the big old [ __ ] boobs I
was like boy boy yeah yeah that like
that everything I'm going yeah I thought
she was gonna I thought we'd see him I
thought she was gonna pop him out you
never see him yes yes you see the tall
girl the tail girl that had the dog
named muffin you did to see her naked
and she was really physically fit for
that air I think she maybe she was a
swimmer or maybe she did well she was
crawling in real good shape you know but
that she was kind of I remember that she
stood out back in those days it's
looking very athletic yeah because that
lettuce ism wasn't really a big thing
for women and ladies early aerobics yeah
but yeah it wasn't really all that much
for men either you know I mean to see a
muscle head was kind of unusual that was
there was some [ __ ] down on Muscle Beach
yeah that's true and like remember that
the main interest movie that kind of had
us a muscle man the kid in the
wheelchair yeah it was pretty built you
know
but he gets killed early gonna axe to
the face and then then that then the dam
the dam wheelchair goes down the stairs
and it's like a damn roller coaster and
I remember that scared the [ __ ] out of
me when I was when I wasn't really 18
just because Jason was like he didn't
even give a [ __ ] that you're know roll
him down the other side she was
traumatizing then the dam hacks going we
saw it again when I have any watch we
laughed man we laughed the whole [ __ ]
time that got going down the stairs it
was kind of funny
I'm not funny if it happened in real
life I know that but it's fine it's fine
through the eyes of people our age and
like looking back on it it's all a gag
when you see when you see the two movies
now through modern eyes you realize that
if they're all magic tricks and gags did
the whole yeah and edited the whole edit
is one big long gag then trying to build
up [ __ ] and they're playing with you
with the soundtrack and they're just
playing games with you through that's
the thing is this very good yeah the
thing is I think that's what horror fans
like and respond to and people who don't
like horror movies or who always like
decrying horror movies I think they all
think we're like a bunch of like
degenerates or something because we want
to see people get chopped up it's not
really that it's almost kind of like
watching you know you're watching like
the artistry or you're watching like how
they it's like how are they gonna scare
me how are they gonna gross me out you
know you know what I mean it's it's kind
of like you're just appreciating the
creativity and the art behind it all
yeah but like I said you know since Tom
Savini did the first one and this is
kind of interesting too in the first
movie like I said where Jason's mom was
the killer that was pretty much where
they were gonna leave it because you
know what they said when we were working
on it we were just trying to a Halloween
ripoff we were just trying to make our
money back we didn't know that it was
gonna become this gigantic cultural
phenomenon that now everybody knows you
show a hockey mask and machete everybody
[ __ ] knows who that is yeah which is
not in the first two movies even if
they've never seen yet and the first two
movies ironically don't have that know
so you know pretty much as soon as it
came out made all the money I think it
was in terms of how like the profit to
you know how much it cost to make and
how much profit it was I think it was
the second most profitable movie at
least for Paramount that year because
paramedic bought it there was like a bit
more so pretty much a year after it came
out paramount was like okay well we have
to make a sequel Sean Cunningham didn't
really want to do it because they said
we'll look our main villain who was mrs.
Voorhees she got to beheaded so it'd be
a little hard to bring her back they
brought her back though um yeah yeah and
he and they didn't want to do you know
Sean Cunningham's idea which was to do
like variations on a theme like I said
John Carpenter wanted to do with
Halloween where it was like a different
story altogether so they're like well
why don't we make it Jason it was the
kid in the first one and then we can
just like kind of you know retcon it and
say that you know the very famous like
jump scare at the end of the first one
where the you know deformed little kid
jumps out of the lake and grabs you that
girl was that was just a dream and so
yeah Jason wasn't really dead so you
know you can kind of like see where they
were going with that
by the way in the first movie um that
very very famous jump scare where the
kid jumps out of the lake that was
actually not supposed to be the ending
the end was just supposed to be you know
her in the canoe on the river yeah they
were gonna roll the credits it was Tom
Savini idea yeah he gave him another
jump scare he had just seen Carrie um
which as you know is have also another
very famous jump scare with like sue
putting the flowers like dreaming about
putting the flowers on Carrie's grave
and then the hand like comes up and
grabs her arm and he had just seen that
he's like okay well we need to end the
[ __ ] on that so that's what they did and
then they had the whole thing with her
being in the hospital and they said you
know we didn't find any little boy so
he's still out there so it seemed like
they left it open for a sequel even
though Sean Cunningham says that wasn't
our intention you know what I mean that
was just kind of like it just ended like
that because we didn't think it was
gonna be that successful so in the
second one they bring they bring Jason
back but he's now a grown person so now
it's like you're sitting there trying to
like figure out what the timeline is
because it's like he's supposedly
drowned in 1957 because that's what his
mom said and then 1958 all of this [ __ ]
started happening at the other you know
like counselor started turning up dead
it's like you know fires started or
whatever and there was like a curse you
know and they closed the camp and then
the first movie which came out in 1980
but they did
tell you like when it was supposed to be
said it just said present day so it
could be any time but even then you know
if they really saw Jason then he was a
little kid still so is he a ghost is he
a zombie or whatever and then the second
one which supposedly happened five years
after the first one now he's like a
grown person yeah I remember it you know
it back like I said this is 1980-81 so I
was probably I don't know thirteen
fourteen around that yeah would have
been about 13 I guess yeah I remembered
that you know me and my buddies were
talking about that well wait a minute
you don't man wait
in part two the female lead explains it
well he must not have been dead the mom
just thought he was dead and he was he
was living out there in the woods all by
himself he saw you know her get killed
that's kind of how and that was good
enough for us yeah I was like okay okay
laws Apple sit there and try to count
out the years well how old is he
yeah we didn't really think about that
they knew the audience they knew that
the audience at the time we didn't care
yeah
the idea as long as it sounded right
plausible enough and in that era
we didn't care too much about continuity
like yes it looked different every time
we care did he we didn't care there's
different actors and a makeup artist it
didn't matter to us we just figured that
the kid the character was evolving for
us we knew this was theater yeah so it
didn't have to be realizing they weren't
selling us realism they're killing us
fantasy so it was what they so what I'm
saying is it's a correct decision that
they did yeah just roll with it the
audience of time loved it and listen I
mean to be honest I saw the second one
before I saw the first one because the
second one was on cable all that yeah I
think so too and I had a second me yeah
I saw it like a whole bunch of times and
then finally I went back and saw the
first one so I had our I was already
very used to the idea from the second
one of Jason being the killer and also
you know because they showed like it the
the second one the the whole like first
20 minutes of it is basically behest of
like the end of the first one so you
don't really need to see the first one
because that's kind
like they show you everything in the
beginning of the second one so you know
and and her like Amy Steele who was like
the final girl in the second one she has
this kind of you know long monologue in
the barber she's talking about Jason and
how he must have seen his mom get behead
it and he was like taking a revenge and
everybody and maybe he didn't really die
like he didn't really drown in the 50s
like he was supposed to have which like
I like he said to me that seemed like a
pretty plausible explanation it's like
it's unlikely sure but it's a movie you
know so the fact that he was just out
there living in this like shitty little
crappy Shack that he had made out of you
know car parts and corrugated I remember
I remember seeing like you said the the
second one first I think yeah because
once I saw part one I remember being
kind of surprised and maybe having to
watch it a couple times to realize that
it wasn't chasing killing all those
people yeah like I knew the mom killed
some of them yeah you know I mean
because Jason was in it he popped up you
know me it's just the thinking of the
time yeah and the order that I saw him
in yeah realized that it was mrs.
Voorhees that had killed all of them in
the first and the first one in Jason
wasn't even really in debt he wasn't
really in it that was a hallucination
because I saw the second one first yeah
so I thought he was killing some of them
but you know it took me a couple times
to realize you know when you're 13 14
yeah you just I just automatically
assumed that it was Jason killed killing
a lot of those people because I could
see man's hands yeah yeah time ice it's
the weapons they come down killing
people it's obviously a man's hand yeah
gotta contain you yeah I was kind of
confused and the hilarious thing too is
the very very iconic scene from the
first over mrs. Voorhees get beheaded
and you can see her head flying off it's
still a really good effect
yeah but the hands that come up like oh
my god those are definitely a bad thing
yeah and like I said I'm willing to like
suspend my disbelief it but yeah so the
second one watching both of them
together cuz we watch them like we watch
the first one one night and then all the
extras there was a second one night yeah
we could I get it I got to find some
[ __ ] to do for matinee though
so I probably need to watch that but we
can watch part 3 - I want to but the
second one I mean easily my favorite
like you know probably my favorite kill
of the whole series the very famous
sleeping bag killed that was from the
seventh movie which I think was the last
one that I saw in the theater but in
terms of quality filmmaking um you know
if you if you want to go that route with
a Friday the 13th series definitely the
second one is my favorite because I
think the first one was a good film it
had like some good tension
I liked Betsy Palmer and a lot a lot I
liked her being the character I like
that twist but it's it's pretty tame a
lot of the times like nothing much is
really happening you know the kids are
kind of not annoying they're all pretty
likable you know Kevin Bacon's very
likable and stuff like that but they
don't they seem a little bit more like
caricatures than real people it's mostly
male gay [ __ ] TMAO gays food yeah where
is in the second one you know you still
get that teenagers in a slasher movie
that well I guess they're young adults
not really yeah there's but you still
get that vibe but to me in the second
movie they seem more like real people
rather than caricatures like they have
like what sounds like natural sounding
conversation yeah boo girl her boyfriend
was like you called it you like that's
that's Mick Jagger he looks just like
Mick Jagger in the neighborhood that
actor's name is but he looks just like I
called her frizzy boob girl girl you
don't know any of their names you forget
their names written he kept like he kept
hoping because like I said she's very
bouncy in the dew net [ __ ] on purpose
oh yeah she's running for the further
toward the phone booth or whatever yeah
and it's yeah the one scene of them like
we're out there all at night like out
you know eatin at the picnic tables and
you nose look like nips everywhere man
it was from another era it was from an
era where boys could not get porn on
their phone yeah this is what you had to
do back in the day yeah you hold your
booze out there you had
you had to rent horror movies and hocus
there was the morning was there some
bush in there yeah really lucky
exactly porn was a [ __ ] you know porn
was a highly controlled substance when
you were a kid back in the bag the
seventies and they I'd be like finding a
key yes kilo it's really it's weird how
many people how many dudes that I've
known that said they found porn in the
woods yeah common was that I guess so
guys it fine it into got kids that find
it in the garbage and then take it out
to the woods stash it and then other
kids would find this - yeah it's like
finding gold yeah cuz I've heard like a
lot of people say that I'm like wow that
seems really weird that so many people
are leaving porn in the woods but yeah
so the second one I mean I particularly
like Amy's steel in the second one she's
a great final girl she's also in April
Fool's Day which I think we might be
reviewing in a couple of weeks cuz I
love that [ __ ] movie but um she's
good because she seems like a realistic
character and she seems like she doesn't
you know and correct me if I'm wrong but
I feel like she doesn't really do
anything dumb it's like what yeah once
bad [ __ ] starts going down and she like
figures it out it's like she doesn't
always succeed she gets her ass kicked
and everything like that but she she's
she's doing what a normal person would
do in that situation without being like
ooh what a badass I am well they're
released fifties and sixties movie
tropes you know that the girls were
always kind of like damsels in distress
yeah they didn't have any peripheral
vision and you get stabbed from behind
but I think I started to notice it with
like alien 1 with Ellen Ripley people
were getting sick of that so they'd
actually make like a realistic female
character and she'd be kind of like to
have the heroine or the heroine of the
movie and this she's kind of like a
Ripley yeah she definitely does seem
like I mean not like a Ellen Ripley yeah
she just seems to do like practical [ __ ]
she tries to talk sense to the dudes and
the dudes are looking at her like man
get the [ __ ] out of here
fight ah that's it girl I'm good at that
scene the scene I was talking about in
the bar where she's talking about trying
to you know ain't it maybe Jason still
alive maybe he's not just a legend you
know maybe all this stuff that happened
like but for like five years ago she's
make it perfect and
her boyfriend and the other like the
kind of Joker character in the bar like
they're looking at her like they're
living each other like why are girls a
lot of times startled a funny the look
that we're giving it but it turned out
was like ah yeah the good old days
yeah but minutes later it turns out that
she's right because [ __ ] jason is
running around now Jason in this movie
and like I said if you haven't seen all
of the Friday the 13th movies you may
not know that Jason did not get his
iconic hockey mask until the 3rd mummy
so the second one in this one he
basically just looks like a hillbilly
with a bag with a bag over his head like
the Phantom killer of Tex Arcana and
he's got a overalls on and they're not
even dirty really they've got new over
he's very clean first hand bum that
lives out the woods
yeah they show his Shack his Shack as
awesome as got his mom's head there and
everything he's old he's putting dead
bodies up around where the head was
trying to bring her back to life is
pretty cool I like I didn't realize it
as many times as I've seen that movie
cuz I taped it off like yeah something
like I watched it over and over I don't
think I realized until I saw it again
recently that the reason that Jason
stacked all those bodies there was
because he was trying to bring his mom
back yeah I didn't realize that that's
why he was doing I thought he just
stacked him there cuz he was gonna eat
him are these just that's where he they
were like a brooms you know he's
offering you know reaping vengeance you
know on the people that had killed goes
to bring her back to life I'm sorry on
your work and yes that's funny about his
I remember how terrifying that dude was
run run in a bag see bag in his head see
my Jason really didn't have a hockey
mask yeah the one that I grew up with
I remembered mostly that damn bag yeah
there's something bout that bag with the
one hole in it in the I go lolly and
around in it you know I mean that that
scared me and we were watching it again
last night he's tussling with that other
dude and I moves like man Jason's kind
of small that's a little dude he's
pretty small yeah he's maybe like five
eight yeah and he's not he's like an
average size yeah dude actually the guy
was fighting with was bigger than him
yeah and I remembered him just being
huge he wasn't later movies but in later
movies my dude rhymes but I just kind of
retro actively kind of put that
because she came across as big and spear
right because he was a serial killer I
guess so
but yeah they when they showed his head
he looked cool look at caveman with long
hair well I think they did a good job
even though um Tom Savini didn't
actually do the effects on the second
movie because he didn't like the idea of
Jason hit neither him or Sean Cunningham
liked the idea of Jason being the
villain because they said well he was
just supposed to be this kid in the
first one he was like a victim and he
was like the motive for the mother
becoming a killer so we didn't really
like the idea of Jason coming out and
being a killer Tom called it but he
called it wrong he definitely called it
wrong because look how much money Jason
made well he worked on later one yeah
like he Connor he was just saying that's
why he didn't Blair was the get involved
in the second that was the way to go
you're someone to keep it simple yeah I
already had a character established they
already had a threat established she go
ahead with that yeah and you can see why
they did that well like I said I can
respect that he didn't really like that
idea like I said I think he did work on
he might have worked on four or five if
I'm Tom got really wanted because he
came out with Creepshow yeah sure he was
talking about he where they wanted to do
love some like creep well he prefers
doing he likes doing the gore but he's
more a creature guy he likes making
creatures which is why he was very
excited to do Creepshow cuz he got a too
fluffy and everything but um yeah so I
feel like so whoever did the makeup on
the second one um did a really good job
of like making the kid from the first
one who was played by I think his name's
Ari fletcher or something like that he's
a musician
you know he was a kid obviously when he
was in that very excited to be in it but
um they did a good job of like doing
like a grown-up version of that it's
funny because on the on the Friday 13th
part to DVD there was a thing that they
did at a convention in 2008 where I
think it was in 2008 the Fangoria did
and they had all the people that have
played Jason yeah so it's had the you
know re who's you know played him as a
kid and then the second guy whose name I
can't remember he was only in the second
one worth with a bag over his head which
like I said it was like the Phantom
killer
so they actually got the bag over the
head idea from town that dreaded sundown
probably I know this though is that
remember I remember really like in 3
when I saw three recently up about a
year ago I was
man this is crap yes this is bad cuz it
was supposed to be 3d and it was like
just too contrived like it was a look at
this I just I want to see it again I
remember the story being pretty bad but
you know from the last time I saw but
when I was a kid I must've been about 14
or 15 I remember - enjoying it
I liked it - I saw that in the theater I
didn't seem to age well but I want to
see it again and I don't know what
happened me and Jason I broke up with
Jason just kind of lost I remembered
certain scenes from movies that came
after that but it never really
remembered the movies or gave a [ __ ]
enough I guess I was maybe outgrowing
that yeah and you know it's getting more
into like the newer stuff that was
coming like predator and all that you
know predator and T Y Terminator but I
just next thing I knew after that I
remember there was like part 10 jason in
space and it's just sometimes 90's and
i'm dumb as hell but it was just pretty
entertain and i'm just like in the
wonder i don't [ __ ] watch friday 13th
anymore like this is terrible
I feel like once they moved him out of
the camps and get don't get me wrong I
love Kane Hodder who played him from I
believe number 5 on really really big
like a stunt dude um and he's great and
he really really likes that character
and I think he's played him since then
although I don't think he was in Freddy
vs. Jason they got somebody some other
stunt man to play him but I feel like
after part 7 like I said the part 7 was
the last one that I saw in the theater
and after that I kind of I think I saw
the other ones but I didn't really
remember them um you know what I mean I
I do feel like some of it once they took
Jason out of the camp setting it's not
the same it's like you know Jason Takes
Manhattan it's I don't want to see Jason
like run around a city like punching
people's heads off and I just don't
remember them being new or whatever just
to remember them being any good it's
just not it's not the essence of Jason
you know what I mean I feel like he's a
woods guy and there's only so much you
can do with that he's not a space guy
he's not like a city guy there might be
some good ones out there but I just
remembered him just getting a hook here
and hook here it was something you could
watch for free on cable and you see it
you roll your eyes out
and the remake also wasn't all that good
it wasn't terrible but it's like I feel
like the remake didn't have the the
essence of the it just seemed like very
generic you're supposed to be a supposed
to be a Friday the 13th video game you
can do there's several I'd cinemassacre
I think he reviewed it because there
probably more than one and it's supposed
to be awesome I've heard that it seems
like something we should probably invest
in and see but yeah I mean of all of
them the second one has like a special
place in my heart because I probably saw
it like a hundred times when I was
growing up and it's you know it's
hilarious we're watching it again last
night
I guess this again this is another thing
that never occurred to me the end of
this movie and apparently this is I
didn't know this but this is like a big
[ __ ] debate among horror fans did the
guy like Paul I think was was the name
of the guy at the end of the movie
um did he die or not because they never
showed her a show they never show it
because apparently what was supposed to
happen at the end of the movie was that
they shot this end where you know Amy
Steele is being loaded into the
ambulance cuz she's fine or or such the
final girl says she lives and they're
loading her image like where's Paul
where's Paul and then they're supposed
to have a shot of mrs. Voorhees his head
which they did have but the head was
supposed to like smile like mrs.
Voorhees was saying that he succeeded
and he killed that last guy even though
they killed him off camera so it just
seemed like a very strange and then they
justified that scene out and so at now
everybody's like did he die what how did
she get away because I remember we would
see that closing shot that head they
would zoom in on her head and me and my
boys are like yeah I think it moved
we couldn't back it up rewind it look at
it again you know I was before VHS yeah
I think it wasn't before VHS is just
that they did we didn't had that he
didn't have one yeah his house you know
because VHS were expensive back in the
early eighties they were a couple
thousand dollars yeah so if you wanted
to watch something had to wait for it to
come on and we were kind of had a thing
going did it move
you did move you know gonna have to
watch it again because like it doesn't I
don't think it doesn't move well because
what ended up it will the candles are
kind of flickering yeah and then maybe
it looked like God and then there's like
a wanted to move maybe well and maybe
maybe that was kind of like psychically
you knew because they were gonna have it
wrong where the head moved like she was
pleased that he died eyes are gonna open
or something yeah although they didn't
it's weird to me that they don't show
and like I said I guess this didn't
bother me when I saw it like back on
cable back in the day but where we were
watching it last time like they didn't
show how she got away from Jason no wait
wait cuz he just like pops through the
window there's like a big struggle then
all of a sudden well you know I guess it
was just back in the day was just a
movie you know yeah we knew about
theater and artistic license and then
you know you could always go like well
maybe in the next one it'll show us what
happened because it read it did that in
the second one and the second one
remember that it went yeah to show you
certain things yeah they let the final
girl from the what happened you just
thought that maybe something had
happened maybe we did show it into later
then the next one will but they never
did show what happened it didn't I think
they did I don't remember if that
happened cuz he didn't come back I don't
think for the for the third one also I
want to point out too before we end that
and I might have mentioned this on
another show but the very famous scene
in part two where Mick Jagger and
frizzy-haired boob girl are having sex
and Jason comes in and Spears both of
them through the bed yeah they straight
up stole that same stone Oh majd it
let's put it nicely from Mario bhavas
Bay of blood AKA twitch of the death
nerve now Sean s Cunningham or Steve
miner who I think written directed or
directed the second one he said that he
had never seen that movie and I find
that hard to believe because the scene
is pretty much exactly the same now if
you guys have not seen twitch of the
death nerve or AB a blood if you want to
call it that it is a very very slasher
esque and this is before Black Christmas
this is before Halloween and this is
before all of that it had the POV shots
it had the whole thing with the spear
with my whole whole thing about like you
know naked people going off it was set
on a lake and everything you know it was
different from a slasher in that I'm not
gonna spoil who the killer is but
the resolution of the killer was more
like a giallo style yeah killer and it's
kind of considered a Jiali movie but it
a lot of the slasher troupes I feel like
came from that and I feel like it
doesn't get mentioned as much as maybe
black Christmas does revisited in these
two movies it was weird to rediscover
the fact that there's very little
violence in them and yeah and if there's
very little nudity in them I remembered
him being a lot I mean being a lot my
like I remember them being a lot more
and particularly the second one because
I've seen it so many times there's
nudity in the second one the love of it
but not much yeah and the thing about it
is that I didn't really even realize
this either even though the second one
is a little more gory than the first one
because the first one's hardly gory is
still not that it's still not that great
and I real and what happened with the
first one I guess the first one the MPAA
passed it without really worrying about
it much about it because they just
thought it was some [ __ ] like
independent movie that wasn't gonna do
anything but the second one because the
first one had been so popular they
started to like go over the fine-tooth
comb now they told Steve miner that it
was going to get an X rating unless he
took like some footage out so I think he
ended up having to take almost a minute
of footage out so the [ __ ] where like
the scene I was just talking about with
the spear through the two people that
was actually supposed to show the spear
going through them but if you watch it
you just see Jason going like that you
don't see her face go Osia
and then you just see the bloody spear
tip you go into the floor like at the
bottom and I didn't realize it was a cut
there yeah it was still enough to scare
you when you were that yes yes
I thought you saw it but you didn't
which you know like I said that's like
the Texas Chainsaw matter of fact it's
like you if you do it if you ended it
well enough you thought you thought you
saw it when you didn't actually see it
but it was just kind of instructive yeah
to watch it again because I'd seen it so
many times and thinking it was kind of
gory and then seeing it again I go holy
crap they don't hardly show anything not
at all but yeah so nothing compared to
what the Italians would do nothing a bit
yeah it's like the Italians were making
way gory yeah like what many years
before that came out so it's really
naked women on screen through the whole
damn movie pretty much some of those
yeah the European ones yeah that's well
that's why there was like a big you know
up sir you know on 42nd Street
in the days when it was a sleaze pit and
it was like all porn theaters the stuff
that's why they would show like all
those that all those like European
horror movies and stuff because not only
were there gory er they really yeah
there's like tits Bush it's like old FUD
they didn't [ __ ] care
they made me hang up it's like you know
what I mean so yeah some of the some of
the Italian ship from like the 60s 70s
with like pretty weird holy crap if they
tried to like release him over here as
an American film the MPA would have like
[ __ ] killed ever dead you couldn't
release him today yes some of them you
probably couldn't yeah um you might get
into travel once yet like Cannibal
Holocaust cannibal ferox stuff like that
it's funny because we just recently
watched [ __ ] Eli Roth that did that
omage to the cannibal movies which green
inferno and I was expecting that to be
much grosser like yeah cuz I was like
you're you're a moshing Cannibal
Holocaust and I watched it and I was
like I would had a couple like little
kind of gross moments but it was like
hardly anything compared to the original
I was like woo you got a long way to go
to catch up with that one yeah but yeah
so anyway I hope you guys have enjoyed
this little rambling retrospective of
Friday the 13th parts 1 & 2 which we
actually finally got around to doing on
actual Friday the 13th I'm so proud of
myself so now I can now I can stop
talking about it but yeah go check them
out they're kind of you know they're not
really that gory or anything by today's
respond though but they are very
important in the history of slasher
movies if you're into that kind of stuff
and you do kind of have to see them you
know if you haven't so go check them out